(upbeat electronic music)
- I'll be honest,
I don't know if you're a one spot, mainly,
no, and the only reason why is
because the first photo
of you looks nothing
like you do now.
- That is true.
(upbeat electronic music)
- [Producer] Can guys
give me a quick explainer
like why each one of you
primarily uses the app
that you use?
- I go with Tinder and Bumble,
but Tinder I feel like I
get a lot more attention on.
- For me, Bumble,
it's mostly the quality
of people that you meet.
- This is me, you know.
- I like the first picture.
- You should leave a comment
if you work on being a better person
for yourself, your
friends, family, society
all while being you're
quirky, goofy stuff.
- I like that.
- This is me reading
to my brother's dog.
- Smart to put a dog.
Very smart. Very smart.
(all laugh)
- So, you know, candid.
- You're verified.
- Got the verified check.
We've got the vaccinated sticker.
Gotta be vaccinated.
- Great photos.
- Oh, wow.
Gotta rock the dark saber.
- This is so--
- Gotta rock the dark saber.
And the bio is, "I just
moved to long beach.
I need someone to show me around.
I'm honestly just a big nerd.
And look, I have no reason to be on here
so let's skip the small
talk and just go on a date."
- I feel like Nick and Rick
are well established people
who know who they are.
And I feel like when it comes
to dating, that's a necessity.
All right. My profile Mauro.
Artist, tattoo apprentice.
- Yeah. This is a great
first picture. Sorry.
- Thank you.
- Dude, your chin, yo,
oh my God.
- Gentlemen by day, philosopher by night,
lover by choice, rebel by fate.
Currently--
- Ooh.
Currently apprenticing at a tattoo shop.
I spend all of my free
time finding scenic views
on my motorcycle.
Pro, I'll cook for you.
Con, I'll eat all the food I cook for you.
- That's fair.
(all laugh)
- I'm honest.
- This is my profile. It's on Hinge.
I first begun with a prompt,
like Toby McGuire is the best Spider-Man.
And then I'm a software engineer.
And then this is just a
picture I put after graduation,
me and my friend we're drinking champagne
in front of our school library.
And then this is just a picture
of me and this dog I found
in Peru. This could be us.
(all laugh)
- That's clean.
- That's good.
- And then is just a
magic trick I did. Yeah.
- Whoa
- Wait, what?
- Can I see?
- Whoa.
- Yeah, I mean, it's in
reverse, but it's the same.
It's ACE to a queen, but--
- Right, so, it's Tyler.
I got a modeling picture, right, you know.
Lactose intolerant,
but willing to indulge
dairy with the right person.
(all laugh)
Yeah. All right. Swipe right if you want,
and then it's got the little, you know,
ticky-tocky thing where it's like, mhmm.
- Okay, if we think about it logically,
these two are software engineers.
If you are just looking for someone
to take you on a date
who can afford to take you on a nice date,
software engineer.
- Yeah.
- I don't know about that,
cause I think it's more like, you know,
they're looking for someone
they can see themselves with.
And you know, I think
occupation can be important
but I feel like, you know,
you guys have a ton of fun pictures
where it's like, man, I
wanna be friends with you.
Let's go. Let's hang out after this.
- You know what I'm kinda,
I feel like I'm pretty locked
into that number two spot.
- You think so?
- I feel like I'm right there.
- Yeah.
- I give you that.
- I feel like my bio's got everything.
Girls like taking photos.
I'm very photogenic. I'm just gonna.
- I'm gonna be honest,
you've got the smarts and
you've got the adventure aspect.
You've got the artist style,
the motorcycle, all that.
I will happily take the fifth
position because my bio sucks.
(all chatter)
- You ain't gotta do that
to yourself, bro.
- Hey, if you wanna
move it, that's on you.
I just thought the rest of the group
brought a little bit more
than just the Star Wars loving nerd.
- I'm gonna put myself here.
- I'll put my--
(all chatter)
- Oh, dude, dude, dude.
I wanted to put myself at
four, now I look like a dick.
- You know, you want me to move it over
to the number one?
- Sure, sure, sure.
- You know I'll take
the number one spot you.
- Thank you, thank you.
- If y'all don't really want
it, I'll take it, you know,
if you guys don't want it, you know.
- I don't really feel
comfortable putting myself
too high in front of other people
just because I think
everyone is different.
- I'll be honest, I don't know
if you're a one spot, mainly,
no, and the only reason why
is because the first photo of you
looks nothing like you do now.
- That is true.
- You look nothing like that first photo.
- That's what I bring to the table.
That's what I bring to the table.
I got so many looks that I
can incorporate into my life.
- I'm gonna put Mauro,
I wanna--
- Do it.
- I'm just sayin', Mauro,
this is your phone, right?
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- I think like.
- Like that?
- I feel like this is.
- I feel like Mauro is
super dateable, I mean like.
- Okay. All right,
I'll take it.
- We didn't touch,
that's cool, yeah. I like it.
- I was actually thinking
you two should go first,
just cause I feel like you
guys are well established
and know who you are,
and not saying that you guys don't, but.
(Rick laughs)
- Your phone doesn't fit there.
- Damn.
- Making moves.
- Damn. Damn!
- That was a big move.
- The outline that I laid out
was definitely not what I wanted.
Well, especially with Tyler,
it's mostly about date ability
and not like a one night sand.
- Right.
(upbeat electronic music)
- [Producer] What are
common things you see
on men's dating profiles
that are either good things or bad things?
- Good things? I would say occupation.
We always look at what they do.
We look at their pictures,
shirtless mirror selfies,
that's something I
wouldn't swipe right on.
Okay, let's see what they picked for most.
Tyler.
It's good.
A lot of emojis.
The last selfie is kind
of like he's into himself.
Next one.
He's verified.
If we go out with any stranger
we just like to know
that it's actually them.
He's into music, black lives
matter, dancing, cooking,
mental health awareness.
Oh, he likes the Jonas Brothers.
I like the Jonas Brothers.
Okay. Let's see Ricky.
Okay, that's a conversation starter,
software engineer at Google.
The best way to ask me out is by saying,
"I like you, you're cute,
let's go on a date."
That's cute.
Oh, these are good pictures.
Okay, Ed, let's debate this topic,
Toby McGuire is the
best Spider-Man, agreed.
Cool, a magic trick. That's cute.
Okay, Mauro, 26, tattoo artist.
I'm known for my ability
to gaze into your soul.
Okay. Very deep.
(smooth electronic music)
(tape cutting off)
Okay. The Tinder one, we
might have to move down.
I prefer Bumble or Hinge.
Tinder seems very hookup.
It's 2021, I don't know,
the profile doesn't really attract me.
Okay. Let's put Ed here.
Let's move him down.
I'm rearranging everything.
Good occupation.
Good pictures.
And the video helps.
For Ricky, he's very positive.
Good pictures as well.
Actually, I might have to put him down.
His prompts are better.
Yeah, I think Nick
Should be in the middle.
He uses Tinder, but he
just moved to Long Beach,
so I can see why.
For Mauro, I think the,
"My ability to gaze into your souls"
a little too deep for me.
We're just on a dating app.
Yeah. Okay. I'm set.
(light electronic music)
So I put Ricky first.
Ed second.
Nick third.
Mauro fourth and Tyler last. I'm sorry.
(all laugh)
I'm sorry.
- Okay.
(light electronic music)
- That's a big, that's a big jump.
- Did you place yourself first?
- Did I?
I feel like no one was
taking that first spot.
- No offense, but you kind
of come off as like a four.
- See that's the thing, yeah,
I get that a lot actually.
I think for me, as a college student,
that's what girls are really into.
That's why I match a lot I think.
But all those people really want
is just like a fling or something.
- And I guess my only question would be,
I know these two are using Hinge,
I know you were using Bumble,
and I know you use Tinder,
does the app make a difference?
- It does.
It depends what the girl's looking for.
On my end, I don't think
girls look for hookups.
I mean, there are a few girls that might
and I would think they
gravitate towards Tinder.
- I'm just gonna delete
Tinder after this now. Yeah.
(all laugh)
- Yeah, I'm done with Tinder.
- I came into it thinking
it was more of a look basis,
but you can have good looks
but it doesn't mean you're hubby material.
- I think it really changed my perspective
of how, you know, the dating app world is.
That was a confidence booster for sure.
- I think I was approaching dating apps
with the intention of being
a bit more attention seeking
rather than actually
attempting to go on a date
with somebody.
And I think the biggest
thing is we need to kind of
abolish this idea of hook up culture
and get back to just humans
connecting with other humans.
(smooth instrumental music)